bonsoir ignazi forte unie merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur air france une
première réaction à ce vote c'était
prévisible
bonsoir oui c'était prévisible compte
tenu de la composition de cette
commission
il ne faut pas oublier que les députés
européens espagnols
dès qu'il a fallu constituer depuis la
dernière les dernières élections
européennes
ils ont essayé de se placer de longs et
afin de pouvoir maillot tu es cette
commission ce qui est assez surprenant
c'est le nombre de députés espagnols
dans cette commission qui est
disproportionné par rapport à ça aux
députés européens provenant d'autres
pays a dénoncé un vote politique c'est
votre avis également d'autres totalement
politique d'ailleurs je pense que
l'europe devrait beaucoup réfléchir sur
ce vote et en particulier vote qui va
avoir lieu aux alentours de 10 mars par
l'assemblée plénière
car j'estime et tout le monde en
catalogne et pas qu'en catalogne mais
tous les démocrates européens
considèrent que c'est un une décision
qui payent qui constituera un précédent
et qui peut être extrêmement dangereuses
compte tenu de la violation des libertés
fondamentales en europe et ce site est
extrêmement négatif comme l'a précisé le
président carlos ghosn tout à l'heure
dans les conférences de presse que vous
avez montré il ya quelques minutes
alors il ya quand même des faits on
reproche à carhaix spéculant d'avoir
organisé on le rappelle un référendum
totalement illégale des fraudes auraient
été abondamment prouvé ce n'est pas
votre avis non pas du tout d'abord il
faut tenir compte que le président tout
le monde comme les membres du
gouvernement catalan en 2017 n'ont fait
qu'exécuter les le programme pour lequel
il avait été élu en tout cas il faudrait
reprocher ça au peuple catalan d'avoir
voté ce qui est c'est ce gouvernement ce
qui est quand même assez surprenant
c'est que ceux ci
nous remet à un point important c'est
que en espagne aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
de liberté d'opinion plus de liberté
d'exercice de la politique pour tous les
certains sujets qui sont à bout et
notamment celui de l'indépendance de la
catalogne
or les ce gouvernement a été élu pour
négocier vérité espagnol l'indépendance
est un référendum d'indépendance l'état
espagnol a toujours refusé de négocier
quoi que ce soit
ils ont toujours il y a eu 17 réunions
pour essayer de trouver de débloquer
situation et de trouver une solution au
conflit
ç'a toujours été non non non et non et
que par conséquent en tant que groupe
que membre d'un gouvernement
démocratiquement élu
ils ont essayé d'exercer le droit des
citoyens de pouvoir s'exprimer
alors ça c'est donc pour la partie pis
la partie fait ce sont les accusations
c'était le cas aujourd'hui devant la
cour des accusations de détournement de
fonds et de sédition les accusations de
détournement de fonds par elles se sont
avérées fausses accusations
ce sont des fausses accusations le
gouvernement espagnol britons que le
fait d'avoir utilisé des fonds publics
pour organiser un référendum qu'ils
considèrent ils ont considéré qu'il
était illégale constitue un détournement
de fonds publics
notamment il faut tenir compte d'un
autre élément c'est que une grande
partie de ces référendum a été organisé
gratuitement par l'ensemble de la
population puisque les institutions de
la de l'état espagnol en mythe toutes
les entraves possibles et inimaginables
pour empêcher l'exercice du droit de
vote aux citoyens et d'autre part en ce
qui concerne la sédition
il n'y a pas de sédition sûr d'autant
plus que le concept de sédition dans le
code pénal espagnol est un concept vieux
concept qui a disparu partout en europe
tel qu'il est défini par le code pénal
espagnol et notamment il est important
de le rappeler c'est que lorsque
monsieur
le président de la junte est monsieur
carlos pizza mode a été arrêté et jugé
dans le cadre d'une demande
d'extradition de l'espagne en allemagne
le tribunal supérieur de justice du land
de schleswig holstein a justement refusé
de retenir le concept de sédition entre
autres parce que ce concept n'existe
même pas dans le droit allemand alors
qu'à respecte on doit maintenant passer
en session plénière clairement vous
craignez qu'il se rapproche de
l'extradition
alors moi je suis beaucoup plus prudent
il est vrai que il y à des prises de
très fortes pressions de l'état espagnol
et que parfois la les institutions
européennes ont trop tendance à tourner
la tête et à ignorer ce qui se passe en
espagne car il n'y a pas que le problème
catalan les libertés fondamentales sont
deux constamment remise en cause en
espagne comme on l'a vu et vous l'avez
montré tout à l'heure concernant les des
chanteurs et des rappeurs mais aussi il
faut tenir compte d'un daim et d'un
élément
important c'est que le président paul
damon dans le cadre de de cette
procédure qui a été engagé il
il faut tenir compte de deux éléments
d'une part maintenant ça sera voté par
l'assemblée plénière
quant aux résultats l'assemblée plénière
je ne sais pas encore nous n'avons pas
d'éléments suffisants pour voir quel
pourrait être le résultat
autant nous étions convaincus que le du
résultat de la commission des affaires
juridiques
mais concernant l'assemblée plénière
j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup de
députés qui comprendront que c'est les
libertés fondamentales qui risque d'être
remis en cause au sein même de tout le
nez européenne deuxièmement une fois
l'assemblée plénière aura pris une
décision si cette décision est de
confirmer
la commission des affaires juridiques du
parlement européen il y a encore la
possibilité d'un recours devant la cour
de justice de l'union européenne
et si la cour de justice confirmait
encore la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire ce n'est qu'à ce moment-là
l'extradition devraient être traitées
par les droits nationaux nationaux des
pays de résidence de ces de ses députés
européens c'est-à-dire la belgique et
qu'il existe comme contrairement ce qu'a
fait cet le rapport de cette commission
d'ignorer les décisions allemandes et
belges
la justice belge a déjà dans d'autres
affaires concernant des indépendantistes
catalans a déjà refusé l'extradition de
ces indépendantistes l'espagne merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
françois